لا توجد لقاحات لعلاجه يفتك بمصابه بشكل
اكبر من فيروس كورونا
وخفافيش الفاكهه هي المضيف الطبيعي له
قاتل جديد ينذر بفصل اخر من فصول الكوارث
التي لا تزال البشريه تواجهها واحده تلو
الاخرى منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات انه فيروس
ماربر
في السابع من فبراير الجاري عام 2023
ابلغت السلطات الصحيه المحليه في غينيا
الاستوائيه عن مرض غير معروف تسبب في
حالات حمى نسفيه
ارسلت عينات الى مختبر في السنغال لياتي
الرد سريعا ايجابيه مرض فيروس ماربر الامر
الذي استدعى رفع السلطات هناك حاله التاهب
القصوى للحد من انتشار العدوى
تسبب فيروس ماربورج في مقتل تسعه اشخاص
حتى الان ونحو سته عشر حاله مشتبها بها تم
عزلها في المستشفيات لاتصالها بالضحايا
كما تم عزل اكثر من 4000 شخص في منازلهم
ومراقبتهم
خطوره فيروس مار برج تكمن بان معدل
الوفيات للمصابين به قد يصل الى اكثر من
88% اضافه الى عدم وجود اي لقاح فعال ضده
حتى الان اما اعراض الاصابه فتشمل الصداع
والحمى والاما في العضلات
والتقيؤ الدموي والنزيف الذي قد يؤدي الى
الموت
وغالبا تحدث الوفاه ما بين ثمانيه وتسعه
ايام بعد ظهور تلك الاعراض
المرض الناجم عن فيروس ماربورج خطير ومميت
هذا الفيروس يسبب حماه نزفيه خطيره لدى
البشر يمكن ان يصل معدل الوفيات الى 88
بالمئه في حين ان مصيرها وفاتيكو في 19 لم
يصل الى اثنين بالمئه حاليا لا يوجد لقاح
وقائي لفيروس
تاريخيا تم التعرف على هذا الفيروس النادر
للمره الاولى عام
1967 بعد ان ادى الى ظهور بؤر تفش بشكل
متزامن في المختبرات في المانيا وبيل جراد
بصربيا بسبب استخدام القرود الخضراء
الافريقيه المستورده من اوغندا في التجارب
لكن اخرا انتشار كبير للمرض كان في انغولا
عام 2005 وتسبب وقتها في وفاه اكثر من 300
شخص
من عائله ايبولا الفتاك ورغم انهما ناتجان
عن فيروسات مختلفه الا انهما متشابهان
اكلينيكيا فكلاهما له القدره على احداث
حالات تفشل معدلات وفيات عاليه
تنتقل العدوى بفيروس مارفور بين البشر عبر
سوائل الجسم من خلال الجنس غير الامن او
الجلد المتشقق وتعتبر معدات الحقن الملوثه
اكثر خطوره في نقل العدوى
ويمكن ان يؤدي الاتصال المباشر بجثه
المصاب المتوفى الى انتقال العدوى ايضا
فهل يتحول فيروس ماربور الى السفاح الجديد
بعد ان سقطت رايه كورونا